hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in plato's dialogue the euthyphro the
end part of it is occupied by a
discussion which tries to frame
piety or the holy in terms of justice
and the reason why they do that
is because in their discussion it turns
out that euthyphro's initial
attempt at defining piety as what the
gods love or what they approve of what's
dear to them
what it is that they like can't really
be
followed through at least in that
dialogue
turns out to be a property of piety and
not the definition of it
so socrates sort of puts a bug in his
ear
saying well maybe it's part of justice
and euthyphro latches on to that and it
makes good sense why he would do that i
want to dwell on that
for a moment when we talk about justice
and we're using it in the sense that
it's used in the platonic dialogues or
really in any
ancient medieval even early modern
philosophy
it has a broader sense than the the
the sense that we often give to it today
it means fairness it means the right
sorts of relationships between
people or in this case people in the
gods it means
following through on things we often
tend to associate
justice with penality or
criminality and its punishment
or with ways in which things are
apportioned in a society for the greeks
that extended much
further and so it would make sense to
actually think of the holy
or or piety on the part of a person as a
virtue
as as a state of being as
being in the proper relationship with
the god so following through on certain
things if you make an oath to the gods
actually fulfilling the oath doing the
sacrifices at the proper times praying
to the gods
at the appropriate times in the
appropriate ways
all of those sorts of things would fit
into it so that's
a fairly natural way of thinking about
this
for an ancient greek like euthyphro and
this dialogue
shows you just how radical
in many ways socrates own theology turns
out to be
because the objections that he's going
to raise are
ones which can be taken in one way for
somebody like
euthyphro who sees the gods as something
like super powerful
versions of human beings and they can be
taken in a very different way
for the kind of theologian if we want to
call them that that socrates is
for whom the gods are these totally
self-sufficient
never doing anything wrong kinds of
beings
so um the suggestion is that piety could
actually be a part of justice and then
the question would be well what part of
justice is it
and euthyphro says well that's an easy
one it's the part of justice that he has
to do and there's a key term here
with service or taking care of the gods
now this is where we get into all sorts
of interesting
difficulties that euthyphro is not
conscious of right away but socrates
is steering him towards because he's
going to ask well what happens when
somebody does
service let's think about human beings
and their service their relationship of
service or taking care
for other beings besides gods
if a human being is taking care of
a flock of sheep the human being is
making sure they don't fall into holes
sheep are pretty actually pretty dumb
actually and have to be watched over
the wolves don't eat them they don't get
let into some place where they'll eat
something poisonous to them
um we go through a whole bunch of
different examples with this
and we can do this for other animals as
well the human being who is taking care
of the animal it's going to be somebody
who's actually competent in that
and they are going to benefit the
animals so you're better off
having your dog under the care of a good
veterinarian
than just you know left to their own
devices or if you're taking care of your
dog
you make sure to get the burrs out of
its hair to
you know comb it for fleas or give it a
flea bath or give it the medicine that
will kill the fleas
unfortunately some ancient grease that
flees everywhere and
couldn't get away from them that's why
they use them in examples
um but in any case the idea is that
there's a relationship not only of care
and service
but of some sort of
accruing to the one to whom service is
being done
and that benefit if there's going to be
a benefit that means that you're moving
from
a case of a worse
to the better
somehow the condition of the gods is
improved by
us doing service to them euthyphro sees
that this is a problem
the gods need to be understood as being
relatively self-sufficient as being more
powerful than us
so in what way am i going to make zeus
or apollo or athena
or poseidon better it's not like i'm
going to come across them
and they're sick and so i give them some
medicine
or they're they're having a down day and
i i talk to them and smile and now they
feel a little bit better
because that's not really the way things
are for the gods
we can't do favors for the gods
in any meaningful way
and so euthyphro tries another attack he
says well
it's not like a person taking care of an
animal
it's more like the case of
masters and
slaves slaves attend to the needs of the
masters
um slaves did in fact almost you know
all of the meaningful household labor if
you actually had slaves
if you were poor your ox was your slave
animals were your slaves as as aristotle
remarks
so what kind of what kind of um therapy
what kind of uh dulaia
what kind of service could slaves
actually give to masters well they can
provide them with
sustenance they can provide them with
entertainment they can provide them
with you know massages when they they
need them they can
do menial work that produces
fabrics they can you know we can run
through a lot of things
but again are any of these sorts of
things
analogous to what human beings
would be rendering to the gods i mean
we can weave a nice cloth
for an altar but
god doesn't need that cloth or the god
or the gods
um you know we can we can kill animals
and and carry out sacrifices and you
know burn the
the particular parts fatty parts and you
know certain parts of the meat and
have the smoke go up to heaven and in
the anthropomorphic consumption of the
gods that the euthyphro's working with
the gods like that sort of thing but
it's not like the gods are actually
deprived it's not like they're actually
in a situation
of need
or necessity the way that human masters
are with slaves that's one reason
why people enslave other people so that
they can get the slave
to provide them with what it is that
they they need
so none of this really makes sense
according to to socrates and euthyphro
sees this problem
um so then they he says you know what
are the the many and fine and noble
things that the gods produce let's look
at the
other side of the the equation
and euthyphro is willing to say yeah
okay i think that the relationship
is actually sort of a two-way
relationship
and this this part over here we must
have gotten that
wrong but we do know that
there's a back and forth here and
justice regulates that
and we know the gods are doing their
part because you know they've created
things for us and they're really
beneficial for us and they take care of
us
what can we do in response to them and
this is
i'm going to use some latin words here
there's an old way of talking about this
don't worry
i give so that you give and one way of
understanding
uh human religion at least certain
aspects of it um particularly in
relation to this can
commerce with the gods is
of a back and forth relationship where
one person gives so that another person
gives something analogous
to like what the greeks had in terms of
guest friendship or xenia
where somebody would go and visit
another person and
when they come to visit they bring gifts
and the other person gives them gifts
they send them away with gifts
and the whole idea is that there's
there's an exchange going on and that
exchange
is regulated by justice
so what's the problem with this
well we know what the gods give us but
what can we
possibly give to the gods
this is where euthyphro is saying that
that piety
or holiness is a science a discipline a
a study of sacrifice and prayer
and so what can we give to the gods well
we can give them
sacrifices and
prayers and now here comes the puzzle
what the hell do they want those for i
mean the sacrifices if if we have a
conception of gods as kind of limited
creatures who actually
do care about the aromatic smoke going
up to heaven and
you know enjoy that sort of thing the
way homer represents them then that that
makes sense
but if we have the the more lofty
conception that the socrates and it even
seems euthyphro's working with
then that doesn't make quite so much
sense
what are we actually giving them in
sacrificing not nothing really
what about the prayer well the prayer is
an interesting part because the prayer
isn't really giving them something it's
asking
them to give back to us we say
uh oh poseidon give me a safe voyage to
egypt so i can bring back the the wheat
or the barley or whatever it is that
they're growing down there
and my ship won't you know go astray or
found her or wind up in some foreign
land where they kill me for my cargo
um there the human being is asking the
gods for that but
why the gods want to be asked about that
that's not helping the gods out at all
so once again it seems very one-sided
and here's the the interesting part it
almost seems as if
this relationship of service or care
there's nothing that the human being can
actually give and euthyphro does
actually try you know one other tech he
says
um what can we give the gods
worship honor
goodwill
again this benefit the gods
is this a giving so that they might give
in return
they don't need any of this but they
like it
and that's the reason we could give it
and now here we get to bet you know the
end of the dialogue because socrates
says
you know euthyphro we just went through
this long discussion
about the fact that you know
the gods like something doesn't actually
tell us
why it's the right thing why it's the
pious thing to do why it's the holy
thing
um we've defined piety in the in the
past as that which is pleasing to the
gods it looks like you're trying to do
that right now but that that didn't work
so if this is going to just lead us back
to piety is what the gods find dear
what the gods like or what the gods
enjoy
that's not really going to help us we
started out with a new
attempt to try to find some definition
of piety in this
and it seems like it leads us back to
the same place
just taking a detour through this notion
of care or
service or exchange between human beings
and gods so that's why the dialogue ends
operatically that is in an opera
in in a not being able to make it
through to crash into the other side
to get you know find a path that will
actually take you through the defile
and give you what the essence of piety
or holiness is for
at least these greeks